if i if i'm okay i bring a guy back to
my place
and we're going into my room like you
you need to ask for my consent
every step i think can i take this step
can i take the next thing
what the [ __ ]
i just think it's like common sense like
if i'm bringing a dude back to my place
but there are women who would say even
if i'm laying in bed next to you naked
oh don't get me wrong you could still
say say no but like then
like i don't need you to i'll tell you
yeah like i'll
obviously things happen naturally
and the way we're built is just natural
like we feed off energies you know what
i mean so you say the consent is implied
yeah by the vibe you're like well she
didn't say no she didn't say yes bro
so i just think here that you see like
in my experiences which are not statisti
statistical whatever
that like i've been on like dates and
then i've been invited back to people's
houses or whatever and if i feel like oh
the night is young i'm not ready to go
home but i would say to me i'll come
back to us i'm not having sex with you
though like it's not a sex thing i mean
i'll put that out there very early on
like yeah we can come we can fight but
when it's time for me to go home i'm
getting an uber do you understand that
i'm not saying even even that even that
is not risky but even that
there's always going to be hope because
the guy is going to be or even the girl
might be like oh the wind can change
that means she might change her mind
anything can change so but this is it
though because if i come back to your
house here on the pretense of like not
in a pretext but like on that that you
know like yeah we're going to come and
vibe we're going to continue to party
like bro i'm not even coming to your
bedroom
yeah but you can you can have sex in a
car like bedroom
no i thought that subconsciously if
you're going back to a man's yard
there's a slight chance it's so insane
but then okay this is gonna be the
second thing that i said now yeah all
right so i i was um seeing some guy
and um but
i i was seeing him for quite a while
before we had sex like
10 11 months
[Music]
and then i basically had to say
something
did you like make it clear like
how did you guys go that long without
having sex like he should be having sex
with other people yeah she has to um
each other in it just getting to know
each other and then i feel like when
like
we talked about quite a lot of time i
used to stay at his house i used to
sleep in a bed with him he wouldn't
touch me he would stay at my house like
like when i was vulnerable when i'm
going through my my bipolar phases or
whatever he'd call me just chill with me
just to beat over that just to hold me
or whatever like he wouldn't touch me
wouldn't be inappropriate or nothing
and then
i stayed at his house one night
again slept in bed with him did not
touch me
and let's test it from now what are you
gay
[Music]
are you gay that's when you have to show
me [ __ ] i am not getting it
i have a question
so have you ever slept with a guy like
really quick yeah so what why'd you make
that guy wait because he's a man
you move like a man
well i promise you there's certain
things about him
i asked her the question no i know i
know but there's certain things about
him that make you want to sleep with him
on the first or second night that you've
seen him i promise you sometimes you're
my man you're linking for 10 11 months
yeah god outside i'm gonna answer now
yeah
so
one guy i had sex with him fairly
quickly
and it was because it was a challenge
yeah
what you set yourself to challenge yeah
i just sent myself a challenge because
he was very like egotistical he would
always oh i'm gonna just get i'm setting
myself up for failure right now
but he would be like oh like like for me
yeah like the way how he carried himself
here like with this person in particular
i didn't care about the before sex
treatment i needed to see how he was
going to treat me after the sex
i had to give it to him fairly quickly
just to know that i've got it like that
and then
because then he was at how's that
wait wait so so you you just wanted to
see how he'd treat you after you slept
together
yeah
how'd it go you treat me very well okay
so because he's like because he okay so
basically yeah like he like i said he's
very egotistical
so like before me even having sex with
him whatever like i would hear how he
speaks to his friends oh girls pussy's
trash this this this and that so i say
to myself okay then so where am i gonna
where am i gonna be on this chat am i
gonna be up here or am i gonna be in the
trash
with him i wanted to rank myself with
him
and then when i ranked myself with him i
was like up here like all the way up
here this guy's thinking that he's a
genius right now like yeah
he's got yourself something really
quickly here what do you need to say is
that you're up here and that's it my man
the difference between that guy and my
man who's looking for 10 11 months yeah
the nice guy the nice guy i didn't sleep
with him not because i didn't want to
because from i met him that there were
sparks there was connection there was
chemistry there was attraction
but
unfortunately
i was kind of seeing somebody else i
know do you know what i think it was
yeah i cannot be sorry to interrupt you
but i think it's because you saw the
spark the connections and whatnot so you
saw it more as a as a husband or a hubby
or a partner and whatnot he is mr nice
guy but [ __ ] boy mr [ __ ] way because you
was trying to prove yourself to him and
whatnot and he was mr mysterious and you
was trying to rank yourself he was more
of a chinese youth that's why
i i accepted the challenge and that's
why you asked him what is he getting but
with no no but with this guy here yeah
the are you gay guy yeah it's like um
i knew from the jump yeah do you know
what it's not even that as well i knew
from the jump as well yeah that if me
and you start [ __ ] each other it's
gonna get toxic it's gonna get so toxic
and i don't know if i'm ready for that
hmm
why would he get toxic you would bully
him
i tried to i think you would wouldn't
even know i don't think i don't think
he'd have it i tried it some man played
the longer he does have it sometimes and
then when he's ready to switch and tell
me about the block
[Laughter]
i'm gonna be your friend but i know i'm
gonna beat but i know i'm gonna have you
you know i mean yeah the [ __ ] boy can
beat quicker
you feel me you're going to call me when
you need anything so i've got you
regardless yeah and even even on top of
that
like not moving to her she's going to be
thinking why is he not moving to me yeah
like every man's on me why do you what
i'm trying to say so some might know
that they'll play that game the longest
yeah and it'll start making you feel
like
but mr [ __ ] boy he ain't got time to do
the long run because he's got a million
other girls that he's lingering
but who would you rather be though if
like what
like you see it's different strokes with
different folks in there some people
have got a higher level of respect
for you than other people in it and that
for instance share that even that me and
him here like even when that he pisses
me off yeah i could say to him about
cool yeah like come to my house and
he'll come and i'll say some okay but
you're sleeping on the sofa
but just for the fact that he's there
with me like do you know what i mean the
security well there's there's like
traits like between like that girls look
for that tend to be
that are inaudible did you know if you
are a convicted
like convicted of a crime you're more
likely to reproduce not less likely as a
guy no way
yeah
yeah it's because of the traits
the traits that make that traits that
make a man the hero also makes the man
the villain
so so for example like aggression the
hero in the story has to be aggressive
yeah but so does
um
so does the villain yeah right
because obviously women like that sense
of security
you know i mean like a guy that's being
arrested or being a felon or whatnot
like that shows that he he lives on the
wild side sometimes you know i mean
so some girls they're men in jail
because they know where they are
okay not to keep going back to this but
so this time that yous were like you
know seeing each other for 10 11 months
and not doing anything did you not kiss
her anything like
who is my man
i could do that easy he would kiss me
like on my cheek and on my forehead and
that just kind of like maybe you fall in
love with him
no see what she said that made me fall
to love him this guy is playing the long
game he's smart robot he's not a nice
guy as in oh i'm too he's manipulating
smart that's what i'm saying that's
manipulation manipulative and that's
true
about his manipulation some guys know
but yeah
yeah obviously but she already said that
she's talking i'm gonna put it to two
okay
what did you say you you get what you
attracted
he knew what he was doing bro for those
10 11 months he knew exactly what he
knew what he was doing yeah
and then my ex is going to be watching
this like what what guy would you say
like i played you know jacob
me too
i don't know what to say to this story
um oh [ __ ]
um okay so
so you're not still seeing that guy the
10 11 months it sounds like she is
she is
she is he's now he's in the picture no
you might not be seeing it but maybe if
he flies me out maybe we get back
together
yo
mr 10 11 months you're being played bro
he's not being probably being played he
knows what he's doing he knows what he's
doing
i think if you're making a man's time
attention and resources and giving
nothing in return he doesn't get nothing
can pretend what did he get in return to
spend time with her yeah oh my god bro
you guys do you guys think it's okay
like vice versa for a dude to sleep with
a girl
like that he knows that she like likes
him wants something more but he's never
going to give it to her
as long as he as long as he's clear that
i'm not really looking for anything else
okay i've told you no but i think in
that instance he's not i've slept with
they've told me they want to be well
then i asked the girls one second oh
right yeah so what'd you what do you
guys think
i don't i don't see myself like fancying
a guy that doesn't like me
okay no he likes you but no no i'm
asking if you think it's wrong i think
you sleep with a girl he knows likes her
but she's like weak for him i think it's
wrong i think it's wrong i think yeah it
is probably wrong but then also it's
just like how you're saying like you
choose to sleep with these people so
okay like you knew that he didn't like
you yeah so no but sometimes you don't
really know when they're no you know if
someone likes you no no no no no this is
what i think yeah like you see sometimes
yeah when a guy knows that a girl
is infatuated with them they take
advantage of that because they know that
that's the weak spot they take advantage
of that and that's exploitation and that
is wrong but you don't think you don't
think you were
but
wait wait wait you don't you don't think
that you were taking advantage of a guy
for 10 11 months i wasn't taking a
flight of him but if he's choosing to
spend all this time with you and you're
not giving him
any i don't think that's taking
advantage he didn't want nothing
returned
he didn't want anything in return
he did like i said he didn't try
anything for me and i didn't reject him
like he was just being respectful i was
going through things and he didn't try
and take advantage of my phone for me he
was being respectful okay
why do you think that that would make
her like taking advantage of him because
it seems like like they're both going
along with it like that's almost a year
i don't think you're obligated to have
sex with someone like i don't think
you're obligated to but it's it's more
like the principle like if
if like clearly he wants to sleep with
you i don't think like we play these
games like like oh he doesn't he like
come on can i add to that yeah because i
feel like whilst he was linking him in
the ten eleven months he was probably
sleeping with other people but you was
using him for your non-sexual attention
no i don't even think it's because
obviously you're using it for comfort in
a non-sexual way i wasn't sleeping with
other people thing is can you can you
really compare it like is it bigger but
the thing is yeah but the thing is what
can you compare what as in like you're
going to have a guy who knows that a
girl's into him yeah but he's just like
leaving what's the equivalent like like
i think that's like the equivalent of
taking a guy's time attention and
resources and giving nothing in return
and what is she taking from if he does
sleep with her what is she is it the
same as a guy because if a guy sleeps
with a girl uh-huh and he's that friend
zone guy i mean he'll be celebrating
that i just got to you know
that's not the same reaction for the
girl the girl's gonna have a probably a
different reaction to finding she's
thinking oh maybe he actually wants to
be with me or something yeah yeah and so
it's like
it's the same action but yeah that's it
i think it's the same but opposite yeah
yeah the feeling is a lot so different
like y'all's probably more emotionally
invested whereas that guy
i don't know if he's wanting to don't
think if he's emotionally invested if he
spent 10 11 months
i don't think so i think if if it's a
guy that's running game you don't it
doesn't bother you if he's got another
his desire in that situation is to be a
friend so he's not lacking he's
fulfilling all his desires and i can get
a letter to come into my yard sleep in
my bed we're we're actually getting to
know each other but quicker than if we
were going on dates and got into the
show yeah i'm going to say in love with
her and she's keeping them off like yeah
if that was the case
but i feel like if
i can see guys doing that and just
feeling comfortable yeah yeah at that
point it's just a mutual thing because
like that's just like shocking to me
like i i can i can go without having sex
like i don't think sex is everything but
if you're spending this much time with
someone and no i don't think so like
that's not the premise of the
relationship but
like if you're spending time with
someone and it's like
we like each other um
more than just platonically yeah um
and at some point like we're gonna kiss
so if we're kissing and you know you're
how does it not like
but it depends on the game plan that's
what if you i don't care what game plan
maybe i am playing the wrong game
because
if you have a game plan going into it i
can see guys doing that with 10 girls on
it's not a thing you get me because in
my mind i'm trying to acquire girls that
i'm that's going to be in my life for
the long term
and i know at any point i've got their
heart whoever they're [ __ ] with is
just [ __ ] no but that's oh you don't
though
are you done i'm not telling you no i'm
telling you i'm telling you i know what
you mean
with you i'm telling you i do get what
you're saying yeah but also like you
don't have their heart because they
don't genuinely like want you they're
you're like their backup plan all right
imagine okay imagine imagine anthony
joshua okay he kind of has that
personality like he's a nice guy yeah i
don't know who that is the boxer the guy
who [ __ ] people up he's a nice guy yeah
yeah
nice guy
you can see him playing that game bro
now you can see him dating a girl not
even wanting to beat and just chilling
for months really
but they don't
they don't lose respect for him they
don't look at him as a waste man he's
like yeah he's hot like in their minds
you feel me so it's not necessarily that
they're they're using them or they don't
respect him there's guys who there's
guys who who win at that game i'm
telling you i can't lie to you i feel
like my guys have played the long run
they're not as respected they're two
women no i like that's what if a girl
really likes you she won't i don't think
she'll make you wait that
way liked him yeah but do you know what
it is yeah like i said i was in a
vulnerable space and i just felt like
all right cool if i'm going to give
myself to you i want to make sure that
that i want to get to know you as much
as i can like i don't want to end up
giving myself to you and then regretting
it after yeah i think yeah that's why i
say a a woman respects a man that she
slept with in a quicker in a short time
let me tell you no do you know why
because i feel like women respect men
that are very masculine i mean it
depends on whether you're a very
feminine woman so i feel like in that in
that instance now men that are very
masculine they're going to wait 10 11
months they would want to get a cracking
sooner than that most men yeah
this guy knows they're better than any
other guy okay but you know what you see
the guy see the guy that i chair really
quickly yeah you see him i have
absolutely no respect for him that's
what i'm saying but to you you see
absolutely for me it was a challenge i
just i just wanted to know
if i could i just wanted to know if i
could suck you in that room
and i just wanted to know if i could
suck you in and i could suck you in and
that's that's all it was like i i don't
have any respect for him whatsoever but
it's like the way a girl
because i feel like there's two types of
like guy like and i hate i hate the man
terms but i think there's like the guy
that a girl views as more like alpha and
that's like the guy she wants to like be
with and then there's the beta she keeps
on the side in case that doesn't work
out
and like you're not with that guy today
where is he
where is he the 10 month 11 month you
said you're happy seeing him often you
just told me you weren't with him
earlier oh yeah not with him that's what
i'm saying that's why i'm saying what's
the game at the beginning if the game is
not to be together then there's nothing
wrong with it if the game's not to be
together even though they're not
together now there's nothing
no one everybody else
out abbey rule yeah um
[Music]
i have temper tantrums
i do i have temperatures
and i had i had a temper tantrum last
week
so because i had a temper tantrum like i
blocked him and everything
okay he's definitely been unblocked by
now
good for you i just
i need
yeah
i'm just i'm weird in it and um like
i need something yeah before i can go
back
what yo what you're seeing what you're
seeing is that this guy's not an alpha
because it's been 11 months or whatever
but he could that's why i said anthony
joshua he's like he's a built boxer he's
like six foot whatever yeah this guy's
an out you can be an alpha and be
patient and wait 12 months like that's
nothing i don't know because i don't
know
it's not alpha or beta though it's like
how does that girl view you
it's how does the girl that's what i'm
saying
like so she has to view you as like the
best she can do
and i don't think a girl like i don't
think most of the time you might be the
exception but i don't think most of the
time a girl's gonna make you wait if
like you are it for her like she like
she like that she has that feeling where
like you have everything she wants like
she's making you wait like she's trying
to figure out her butts like what's your
butt